on the hill today for the giants will be
the right-hander trevor cahill making
his third start and here is the first
pitch
and it's hit on the ground to second
and the throw is wide but staying on the
bag is belt and that's how this game
gets started peralta two for three
lifetime against cahill
got him and that'll end the inning
giants are coming up diamondback
starting pitcher the right-hander luke
weaver he's had great numbers in this
ballpark three in one lifetime with an
era of 1.99
in four career starts at oracle park
mike kastromski the right fielder
celebrating a birthday today
nice come back to there for luke weaver
brings up yaztrenski went away here's
the left fielder alex dickerson
called strike three
adam hammery brings up dickerson two
down in the first wilmer flores
97 right by wilmer one two three go the
giants of the first stunning very very
impressive first inning for luke weaver
christian walker is going to lead things
off
got him
perfect backdoor sacred wow
dorian out the backs have three
defenders on that left side of the
infield
double play ball if cattell can handle
it himself no problem
two down nobody off three two swung on
and missed strike three into dirt third
strikeout for cahill we head to the
bottom of the third nose scorp i'll
bring up brandon crawford the
left-handed hitting shortstop bang goes
flying
and crawford strikes out swinging
doesn't even attempt to run so vote
doesn't have to tag him for strikeout
for weaver and that's out number two
here in the third inning
nothing ball game ahmed vogt and
varshall
got him as far pulls on six strikeouts
okay
vote pops it up again this is a long run
for somebody
and it's going to be
joey
makes a great play
[Applause]
and listen to these cutouts
that's one of the best we've ever seen
and he had to go a long way then he
finally committed to it and he has to go
to a backhander as you know he's
learning the stadium and balls will
start coming back
towards the field
what a great play so two down nobody on
here is marshall
got him that's five
shutout innings so far seven strikeouts
delta is the only hit for the giants
belt hits one high to right field
calhoun back
calhoun at the wall he leaps it's off
the wall
delta's on the move and he's gonna
drop anchor and he's got a double
longoria rolled out to a double play in
the second
[Applause]
hit to right
calhoun over and he's going to have to
play this one off the bricks it cares
away from him that's going to allow belt
to score and the giants are on the board
is longoria comes through on an 0-2
pitch
he's hit can give the d-backs the lead
and here's peralta who leads the team at
rbis
struck out twice against cahill david
lifts that one high in the air
yastremski backing up still backing up
at the wall and he's got it
the runners will move up cole calhoun
comes in starling into third and we're
tied at one on yaza's birthday he's
struck out and he's rolled out to first
get into center field and hit well on
the move is marty still on the move at
the wall
out of here
and on his birthday yaski gives the
giants the lead
his seventh of the year
is dickerson his last at-bat was the
line drive right at cold cow
high fly ball down the right field line
calhoun looking
up is outside
and that is a three-run home run for
alex dickerson who picked a perfect spot
to hit it sandoval you figure he's gonna
attack two ups and a single
line drive base hit
coming in to score his belt and the
giants now lead six to one
against end of all his
fifth rbi of the year guys with a six to
one lead as we head to the ninth inning
so harleen garcia comes in for the
seventh time
and this is head out to ustremski and
this should be the ball game
giants end up sweeping the d-backs in
this
three-game series they
have won six straight so
a team that was
dead in the water
after tommy la stella hit one out of the
park on monday
has won every game since then
and they've done it with hitting
pitching they've done it in every
different way